so the samosas remaining list and this
is this awesome database library key
values for library it's now github
there's an interesting tool a slice
wishes if that's not database unless
okay so don't give up as both PB slash
Walt it's approaching primarily by Ben
Johnson was an awesome dude it writes
really neat code if you're looking to
understand something that's a little bit
early with like laudable details but we
really bring that source code isn't
really experience
oh my god both have been mostly to be a
sounding board or API decides and
features a user so value school it's not
a whole database it's not a sequel
database definitely not it's a key value
store doesn't have this body and
basically you open a while you do put
operations where this key is this value
you do get operation where you're giving
the key and all of these are quite
slices so there is no like numerical
values none of that stuff that belongs
in your application or a rapper you
build on top of all that we understand
data types as far as all this con said
everything is a bite-sized and we'll
talk more about pockets later so what is
yoga and that's one reason why it's so
amazing like why why I enjoy using it
was inspired by a protocol L M VB which
was written for open L back to back it
has the same basic design but it is not
a cohort of Allen TV has different
design goals and they are starting to
deviate from each other
Walt is explicitly as simple as it
possibly can be if even if that costs a
little bit of performance don't choose
to be simple and understandable LOD B is
performance nuts written in C or C++ I
forget which one and explicitly meant
for that sort of style both is simple
yoga and use what is a library it's not
on network service it's not something
that once independently of your
application it is a part of your
application and it is which we applaud
for words that you've used through this
library so it's a single file which
makes it really easy to manage you can
write network based on top of it but
it's probably providing more value in
surgical operations and influence PB
which is the second form of today is
kind of an example using Walt in your
own application but databases are meant
to be used by a single process so there
is a single owner of the database one at
a time so if somebody has been a it's
open nobody else
and the e-value store is ordered so you
can move the keys in order so this is an
example of first thing you have to
remember is the keys and the values are
just white slices so to be able to have
a meaningful order we need to encode our
values in a way that preserves the order
so here we're doing a zero panic
decimals we're doing zero panic decimal
strings after that he in your real
application you probably do something a
little bit more finer but the same idea
is there so for example big-endian is
preserving four integers so we go
through and put in 100 random keys from
0 to 999 and then we walk through them
in a form and what you get out is you
get a listing off so then we get them in
water okay so what are key values for
also lets you access data by other like
gimmies like you can ask for anything
with this prefix so we stored fortunate
decimal numbers and we can ask for
anything that begins with a foreigner 0
in our 100 random numbers
you can ask for range by encoding both
beginning and ending T the way you link
up keys and walking up cursor from the
beginning key to the ending key as long
as you don't go past the maximum key so
it's kind of been simple but you can see
how this is no like writing a sequel
where you're actually like programming
it with a very low level mechanism this
actually feels like I'm using it in like
a container of some sort would have this
API now it just is a persistent data
structure so both actually is a plus
tree underneath that's what's stolen in
the file and is saying the plus tree is
annoying and technically trees are
something slightly different
I just what I'm gonna say Petri and it's
gonna be at least no matter okay so it's
an a copy on write B tree that begins
with two marinated pages which one is
newer is the one that wins so when we're
opening the database recovering from a
crash or whatever which one of those two
metadata pages as a highly staff
generation powder on it that were mixed
and that page contains the rest of the
rest of the stock is data pages
containing pockets that we talked about
anyway when you do any transaction and
an octane transaction a right
transaction first you writes out all the
dirty data pages to new locations so
that's the human right and then it
writes over there other the redundant
better image which now becomes the new
so every single right transaction that
you do is to death Watchers to disk six
transactions hit the data that would
otherwise be recycled at home from being
recycled but it's a big popular yb3 that
uses the file as its storage so it has
woman good and bad size of the trees in
general and one of the popular
alternatives that gets mentioned is
Alison's like leveldb for example and ah
these two are completely different in
design but use for similar purposes
which might lead to the question of
which one should we use well the basic
side line is this level pp was decided
to take bragging rights and convert them
into sequential writes as they go to
disk and the thing that benefits from
that is spinning disks soul Emily is
really intended for right candy
operations running or spinning lists it
benefits from SSDs but every is designed
for spinning list B trees tend to have a
lot of random accesses which while they
still hurt we
jeez they took significantly less so
both is really good when running on SSDs
and in general the design is flipped all
the way up the other way around so where
are they well structured merge street
light lovely need is bright heavy and
redirection slower than Heights all is
the exact opposite asks heavy of a great
load you can give it's built and the
other thing is that whereas all the time
but it's the comparison against another
thing that is enough similar wrong so
one of the reasons that makes port
pleasant use is because it's simple and
one of the major ways it is simple is
because it has a single rider at a time
touching the neighbors so if you think
about your odds are more like how you
read account the increment the number
you store it back now something gonna
happen you can't do that you will have
conflicts with two updates happening at
the same time well both is explicitly
designed so that that never happens so
doing the dumbest possible they fighting
the single
is actually what is meant to happen with
water you don't need to have this
elaborate for example is sequel you need
to actually write a query that does the
thing you want instead of reading the
value into your application doing
something for it and putting it back in
so what is is you look like programming
and writing in something yourself
did that make sense and I actually
prefer my data structures have been
complex and there's a lot of intricate
bits going on so I like to guarantee
that when function f is updating the
database no one else is and this is
called serializable as a property and
it's like most fungus things you could
ever say about the database and it costs
some performance but it makes things so
much easier to think about that I'm
going to and this is what electrons
actually looks like so you call the
method DB update and you give it a
function
you give it a function that takes a ball
transaction and returns an error and it
may do things to the transaction to
greet and write the database if it
returns an error it gets rolled back if
it returns successful the comment goes
through unless there's a disk error or
something like that so the old storm but
this is the actual error that comes
whether it went for a moment but
essentially if you say oopsies I take
that back and return an error or
understand it and to me I don't know
about you but I like writing these
little functions I feel like I don't
need a DSL and they're in string
in my source code which is my annoyance
with just about every possible thing is
like I'm breaking another language
inside there's the one language why am i
doing that it should feel what this
feels I don't even go all the way and
read transactions look really similar
but instead of updating we say to you
and the trick to know about this is that
all the things you get out of walls are
only valid within the transaction in if
you return from that function there if
you still hold a copy of the value you
got from pocket don't get things will go
wrong they will not be the same as what
you asked to look at so lifestyle of
everything you receive from fault is the
life in the scope of the transaction and
that's one of those things that I mean I
made that mistake like as discovered in
white two weeks ago I had made that
mistake I was in my quest for six months
I think
so it's an easy mistake to make but this
is a fundamental and anything that would
do like if you guys have used to sing
it's a way of life instead of churning
through garbage training that the
garbage collector it has a fool of
objects that are like manage a little
bit more explicitly he has the exact
same thing if you return an object into
the pool it's essentially the same as
the old C used at the free bar it's kind
of the same thing except the language
makes it a little bit safer but it's
still like that's that's what
so you kind of that's the one so we
talked about having a single right so
what about the freezing side so we can
have at most one right transaction at
most one update all-time happening if an
otherwise it will wait until the first
wall complete that makes no sense freaks
you want to have as many reads going on
at the same time as possible that's what
when it performs even the sequel
databases you have this thing for
isolation levels which is like how the
database vendor describes the behavior
of the database for your queries
snapshot isolation is pretty much the
storms possible thing you can say about
a sequel database so what is that level
so once again it's really the most easy
to reason about so what happens is when
you start the transaction you call TPD
warning when you call DB of view you
have a snapshot of the database as it
was at the time your transaction started
and throughout this whole function you
will be reading that same snapshot so if
you read the same value again it will
still have a same value so here's an
example of that we have a driver that
will every 100 milliseconds write the
current time of day into a single key
and we delay a little and then start a
transaction that also delays a little
and then we say we are
so what happens when I run this is that
you get a bunch of updates so you have a
bunch of updates going 0 1 2 3 4 you
have regular updates to clock and the
transaction started here by only read
the value here and it's still seeing the
old value so it's deceiving a snapshot
of the database which makes it easy to
reason about things don't mean take from
underneath the money you start the
transaction you have a consistent world
and one of the things that makes all my
suit nicer than any other key value
stores is that you can use nested
pockets to kind of structure the data so
instead of needing to cram everything
into a single main space where you know
you need to income into the key that
this is my customer I need this and this
is their whatever you can for example
customers each customer into a separate
pocket and underneath that customer for
example every boy word for us is a new
pocket and other that is something so
you even structure the Dana with pockets
that are essentially like folders where
even values are like waffle contents
does that make sense
so markets are created with an or create
market and you just get a reference to a
market object and you can call methods
on that to dig in deeper whatever makes
sense to you for your application and
once again these things the scope of the
bucket value is the transaction so you
can't hold alter and when you use them
you just asked to get the bucket by this
name
and it's library nil or you get the
actual bucket and you know if you call
up bucket the top pocket method on a
previous bucket it's a self pocket and
solar and there's essentially no limit
on how deep you can dig witness there's
a little bit of overhead so you don't
miss we want to create a pocket turn you
know an object a struct wherever you
feel is a key that's a little bit much
so it's it's once again wall there's no
talking it's cool
so what you have is you have the
database that has transactions waiting
to it and one of those transactions is
special right transaction there can be
only one records actually
and inside those transactions you can
you have curses that are either doing
its rating the top level or you have
pockets and pockets can point to other
markets
but this is essentially just a
hierarchical tree accessing a key on one
of the really neat things fault is the
way it's implement and this is logic
either that LM VP inspiration here so
what they've done is that the whole
database file is memory not as a
read-only young man that file literally
is in memory as far as everything is
concerned accessing that range of memory
reads from the file without needing to
do like Cisco without meaning to
explicitly ask for why are not read
where none of that sort of stuff that
while this in memory and the read-only
math makes it safe so you can't
accidentally write over it so what what
does it go you to edit it when you
commit a write transaction when you go
update it writes to the file folder
reading goes through the ml so if your
machine has enough memory it behaves as
if it was an in memory because tree
which is kind of awesome when you think
about it because usually like in
everyday instructions are fast and more
distant instructional slot but now
three is small enough to fit into memory
it literally is an in-memory data
structure and there is also no like
double hashing where the database
library needs to maintain a row cache or
something and you know go through life
this is within the 1000 most requested
rows let me hold it in my patch all of
that is done by the kernel and the big
benefit of that is that first of all the
kernel you can sort of assume that
kernel run we do well written by smart
people and take the ball the ball so it
doesn't matter what gets thrown out of
memory it could be possibly a database
it could be that JPEG that you haven't
served anyone for a while you know what
patches it could be popular executable
that is only used once a month
everything unnecessary gets thrown out
of memory to make room for your database
or if something else more required your
database gets thrown out of memory
because it wasn't active needed thing so
it's just it's this BND
thing where frightened simple things
create something beautiful that performs
well just when everything just clicks
together so this is why you can't hold
on to the get return values for example
because those white slices audition
pointless points in this region of
memory and now remember it was a copy of
might be tree with white you know space
being freed up and reduced so there's no
guarantee when
this bit of memory
we used once in the transaction
transaction wanted pinned to the old
usage but when the transactions that
memory can be replaced with something
else some other content so that to me
like I knew LD be people all existed and
I was writing that's the only winner I
like that it makes read operations
really easy and lightweight I think a
real operation right now is something
like data centers so it's what happens
if you try to accidentally accidentally
change the values returning so you get a
paging baby there's paper reading that
you try to write it so if you ever see
this you kind of know what you did you
probably failed to allocate a new buffer
and copy this value minute so the
downside of being memory mat is that the
opening pages are exactly what the
colonel thinks they are I can say what's
all of this
that is fungible but all database pages
all of the kernel things that are so
there's no load operation
during which we could do decompression
like leveldb for example when it writes
up chunk of the disk it compresses it
with snapping and when it loads it from
this it decompresses it with snapping
now with both there is no such thing as
lovely it's just memory axises so there
is no like convenient moment to
decompress anything and I kind of think
that that's kind of necessary because
these days a lot of stuff can response
for you so for example with one request
you can tell this ball confused or
compressed and three advanced what if
you say it won't my files on this disk
should all be compressed there's also a
capital C which says hey butter on us or
any other hope you like all system don't
give me the copyright for a protection
that you know native files because this
is a update in place file so you know
avoid that overhead because it is
pointless wasteful and it's the same
thing to press my virtual machine disk
image back as you know individual rings
it's not like a single file that gets
rewritten from scratch so you can kind
of optimize how things are done if
you're not using one of the fancier ones
one of the principal substance that has
this stuff you can also put the whole
box right the whole block device or
something that compresses things on the
fly so DM compress is a block level
but that connects the downside is that
you don't have a flexibility of having
custom code that launch things from this
because the molding is not occur okay
what is decidedly lower in case it has a
kind of come through yet
is like this is not really bolts problem
this is the application problem a lot of
things these things actually come to
kind of even the one in the application
because then you can do things in a way
that is small antics and bat-signal but
you know in the application so what does
it do things like schemas indices
queries there is no DSL there is no like
filtering off give me all the keys that
have the but value hello there is no
such thing you are you walk through all
of them or you write an index that helps
you do that thing and what I kinda wanna
see is a little ecosystem or indexing on
top so for example there's no reason why
there's that project the LPE that's
essentially a search engine that the
guts of a search engine
written window there is no reason why
you couldn't take one of those things
that is very generic thank you and store
the index in both or whatever and
updated from your application but that's
kind of outside of the problem domain on
both itself and that's actually we
really
because you know that all this pretty
much gonna be what it is like it's not
something guys gonna live that's two
years and would be something else I kind
of like this very stable now we're still
talking about some addition some minor
API changes Bob we feel like it's it's
pretty much like definitely a one-point
over there
so a good example of what is no boss
problem is when some transaction - so
the idea of in the same disk sink doing
multiple updates in that one
synchronization operation and this is
something that a sequel innovation into
point it will combine multiple queries
that you send in transactions that you
send in it will combine those and do
multiple at once especially when it's
sequential so like imagine the idea of
you wanting to import a file that has 10
million lines and you create a key for
each line now the trivial way of doing
is read align closet update set one key
read the next line passing updates at
the key the problem with that is that
you're doing to full distinct for every
line that's 20 million distinct
so what you do instead is you want to
match both panting one so let's say you
come on 1,000 bytes do a transaction
that writes go down and you can make
this if you're trying to specially batch
them instead we need to actually do this
batch and then check whether we are
doing anything week on TV door badge
which is taking concurrent operations
and learning those into a single
transaction so for example if you have a
weapon
I'm API of function that takes incoming
requests and there's something to the
database as a result of those requests
it with this thing let's say anything
within the same 10 milliseconds of total
of 1000 operations gets put in one
transaction so we have that is for
concurrent no so what is a key value
store so no relational databases they'll
see more little queries nothing like
that simple is it's a free program
surprisingly small
it's a library it's not a service it's
not even you run it's something that
becomes a part of your application it's
a been to be the vault database is meant
to be used from a single process so you
really on the file and
so B plus trees opportunity is based on
the idea that being at most a single
rider at a time to the database and that
makes application one degree symbols
right on the inside you get snaps of
isolation which means whenever you're
reading from the database you have a
consistent worldview
you don't have to deal with things
changing run it from underneath you and
you can use nested structure your
application may not do what you want you
need to embrace the fact that it is just
one of the things that I really enjoy
using it it has been a great match for
my application I'm like here like you
maybe later on come to me and talk about
like I have this in this thing
you'll be useful this in this that's all
conversations are useful good question
yes there is so along with if you read
the file that innovation one from
outside the process it can change from
underneath you so that's not a safe way
to do that so what both actually passed
in the library is you can call a
function and it will essentially write a
copy of the database that is a snapshot
also which you have any solution at all
that can give you that's all these
snapshots which for example arrest us
that's a perfectly valid way of taking
about because what is crash stick so if
even if you kind of catching the middle
doing changes
okay yeah fine under what circumstances
do you read static
reestablish the m9 sorry go line yes so
Emma is a fixed strength remember you
can swipe change the size of it with our
in mapping something else so when the
database runs out three pages and needs
another free page well it does is
then so must out a comment all these to
write all of the dirty pages make sure
they are stable on this then right now a
new metadata page and make sure of that
stable on the disk and then it says
we're done so every transaction every
update hold costs two disks X and that
kind of is correct
honestly how much data you write is
almost irrelevant because it syncs
themselves of course now an SSD will do
like that some hundreds of 6% so that's
your winning and that's what the
motivation for the batching mechanism
comes in the read side when things go
well it's literally an in-memory deep us
tree and I am getting timings of coins
so what is definitely meant to be a
retaining solution and the way I think
of it is if you're building something
that is not so what is not a network
service in itself so there is no such
thing as multiple things coming to both
directly so there is always more
application mediating that conversation
from any clients you have so in that
sort of situation your application is
the perfect place to do some sort of
fashion and get it was doing charge of
error handling what if the cache fails
you know that's also indeed be bad for
your average Network
something in the style of offices coming
in on requests coming in TV bash is
pretty much what you need it's it's
close enough to the perfect solution